- Good morning, Believe Nation.
Today's message is find your gift.
Over to you, Cicely Tyson.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- There was a time when I had
two or three jobs in the same day.
I'd go here and do a little bit,
here and do a little bit,
and people began to talk
about this new actress,
Cicely Tyson.
And next thing I knew I was,
here in front of you.
(laughs)
My mother wasn't happy
about what I was doing.
She didn't like it.
She told me I couldn't stay
in her house and do that,
whatever that was.
I was called by Vinnit Caroll
and asked to come and read a play
called Dark of the Moon.
And it was to be done at the Y in Harlem.
My mother heard that I
was going to do this play.
She told my sister,
"Hmm, she's going up there
and make a fool of herself."
Okay.
So I decided to invite her.
And she came and she brought a friend.
I made sure I knew exactly
where she was going to sit
so that I wouldn't look
in that direction, okay.
From the moment I walked out on the stage,
I heard her say, "Oh my god."
She kept talking to her
friend all during the time.
She thought she was whispering.
But I could hear every word she said.
It drove me crazy.
At the end of this play
I come out and my mother
is standing at the door,
accepting congratulatory
remarks from the people.
(laughs)
"Yes I always knew, ever
since she was a little girl,
that she was going, you know
she like to sing and dance.
And so I always knew she
was going to do this."
I said, "Wait a minute."
My mother who put me out of her house
and didn't speak to me
for almost three years,
is standing there telling
this bare-faced story
to these people.
Right?
And so I knew that it was something
within me
that she felt
was a gift.
- So I'd like to say that Michael Jordan
is not the greatest
basketball player of all time.
The greatest basketball player of all time
is a manager at Starbucks.
Because he never laced up.
Because he never realized
that that was his real gift.
And I think that so many people
walk through life that way.
I think so many people have
not discovered their gift.
Maybe not you guys as
part of Believe Nation.
But I think most of the world
has not discovered their gift.
And they know they should
be doing something else,
but instead they're doing this thing.
Because it's safe,
because it's comfortable,
because it's convenient,
because it pays the bills,
because, because, because, because,
all the practical reasons why
we do the things that we do.
Instead of following our heart
and doing the thing
that we should be doing.
I think that's super common.
I think we all have Michael
Jordan level talent at something
and most people have barely
scratched the surface
of understanding what's possible for them.
If you don't know what it
is that you want to do,
you need to explore.
Say yes to things.
Try things.
That idea that you have,
just get started on it.
Find some small way to build momentum
and get started.
What we tend to do
is we build this dream up
in some big huge thing.
This big vision that we want,
which is amazing, I love the thinking big.
But then because it's so big,
we don't take any action on it.
We tell ourselves that we can't do that
until we have funding,
or can't do that until I meet this person
or I get this connection
or I move to that country, right?
We build up all of these things
that have to happen first
before we do anything to go
an accomplish that big goal.
And guess what happens?
Nothing.
You just sit on that idea
for the rest of your life.
And you die with your
song still left inside you
instead of releasing it to the world.
I love the big thinking.
I love the big vision and the dreaming.
It's important.
It's motivating, it
drives us, it's inspiring.
But at the same time you have
to take action immediately.
As soon as you set some
big huge goal for yourself,
that day you need to start building
some kind of momentum to it.
If your big goal is to write a book,
and have it be a best seller,
and get it published
through a major publisher,
that's what it is,
you got a book inside you
and it has to come out.
Start, start writing the book.
Start researching authors
and how they had success.
Start going to industry events
and getting to know what
the process is all about.
Start trying to line up
coffee meetings or interviews
with people who've had
some success along the way.
Look for meet up groups in your local area
to stat building some kind of momentum.
Something, take action.
You want to be a YouTuber.
Great, start.
Build a channel, make your first video.
It's going to suck.
That's okay.
Do it again, and do it
again, and do it again.
Whatever that big dream of yours is,
you need to find a way to
get started immediately
and build some momentum.
And if you don't know it, then you explore
until you find the thing
that makes you come alive.
And at the beginning,
this really important,
at the beginning,
it's from here.
The thing that you want to do
is not going to make
any sense practically.
You're going to come up with all
of these practical reasons why
you should not go out and do that.
And so you're going to
stay on this straight path
that you've been on before.
But how happy are you?
And imagine fifty more years
of doing this same thing
that you don't like doing.
And it doesn't mean that you just
throw everything away and
go all the way out here.
You don't have to burn
the boats necessarily.
I'm not that kind of person.
But you have to do something.
You have to take a little bit of time
away from this straight path
to play out here.
Because if you don't,
you're never going to
do anything out here,
you're never going to get there.
Daily consistent action of some kind
towards the attainment of your dreams.
It's important.
Everybody has a dream.
Everybody has some big
thing that they want to do.
And 99% of people just
complain why they can't do it.
Don't be that person.
You already have the
resourcefulness inside you
to move forward on your dreams.
Now what are you going to do about it?
Take action or complain?
Get to it.
So the question of the day today is,
I'm curious, what is that
story you're telling yourself
as to why you're not going out
and accomplishing your bigger goal.
What are you telling yourself?
What's the reason?
What's the excuse, what's the complaint?
Put it down and then laugh at it.
And understand that
you're better than this
and remember who you are.
Leave in the comments,
I'm curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Calvin Simpson,
Calvin, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word.
Really means a lot to me
and I hope you are enjoying the read.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
Hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see you
guys again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- I just really worked on my gift.
I realized that all of
us are born with a gift,
but you got to hone it.
You're not going to become great,
and we talk about the school of greatness,
you know we talk about,
you know, greatness is upon you.
And I realized that my gift
wasn't going to create itself.
My gift wasn't going to nurture itself.
My gift wasn't going to perfect itself.
That was something I had to do.
And so, man before you know it,
we did a video that went viral.
I think it's got over 50 million hits now.
And we turned our passion into our profit.
- I love it man, I love it.
- Your gift can be anything.
You can't look at it as
simply running, jumping,
singing and dancing.
But I tell you one thing,
your gift is the thing that
you do the absolute best
with the least amount of effort.
For me, it was comedy.
So once you identify it then,
that's the beginning of it.
But there's a lot of work to do
even after you identify your gift.
You can believe you're
something or you won't,
but if you don't work towards it,
you just sitting there,
it's going to be empty.
- Well my message to the
youth pretty much, man,
is to follow your dreams,
you know what I mean.
I think a lot of people get caught up
and get side tracked
by what's happening around
them and what's cool.
People always ignore their gift,
not realizing that gift is
what's going to take you
out of your poverty, take
you out of your situation,
that gift is the ultimate element
that God provided for you to
get you out of any situation
or to take you to what
you're destined for.
You know, some people they're
just great at certain things,
but because music or
modeling or film is cool,
they alienate what their gifts are
just to be a part of something that is
pursued to be or persuaded to be cool.
So I always feel like, you know, my method
and message always has been
just follow the gift that you have,
put a lot of emphasize in it.
Concentrate on what you
feel that you're great it,
because what you're great
in is always going to be
what pulls you out
of the worst situations
that you could ever imagine
and put you in a better
situation like we in today.